Wes: Now we're going
to learn about destructuring.
Along with arrow functions, let,
and const, it's probably
something you're going to be
using every single day. I find
them to be extremely useful in
the code that I'm writing.
What does destructuring mean?
It's a JavaScript expression
that allows us to extract data
from arrays, objects, and
something called maps and sets,
which we're going to learn about
it in a feature video, into
their own variable. It allows us
to extract properties from an
object or items from an array,
multiple at a time. Let's
take a look at what this problem
really solves. Sometimes you
need to have top level variables
like const = name or first =
person.first, constlast = person.
last. You get the point. You do
this over and over, and over
again. You've got this pretty
much repetitive code over and
over again, where you need to
make a variable from something
that is inside of an object or
inside of an array. What we
could do instead of doing two
variables, or six, you could say
const and you open up a curly
bracket. That is not a block.
That is not an object. It's the
destructuring syntax. We say
first last = what? Person. Now
what does that do? That says,
give me a variable called first,
a variable called last, and take
it from the person. It's weird
because we're not setting the
entire object, but we're taking
the first property and the last
property and putting them into
two top level variables. If I
save that now and I say first
and last, you'll see that we get
Wes and Bos, because I've
created two top level variables.
Similarly, if I also wanted
twitter, I would just add
twitter into that, and I would
get a third top level variable
inside of my actual scope.
That's really handy in many use
cases. This is just one nested
level, but for example, in react
often you want to use
destructuring because the data
is so deeply nested. Let's
take a look at some nested data
here. I'm going to make another
variable down here called Wes,
and we've got a first, last. Now
this data is something you might
get back from an API where it's
really deeply nested. I want
to be able to pull out Twitter
and Facebook URLs here. I could
do this, constTwitter=wes.links.
social.twitter. Then we also
want facebook, so I will just
add facebook and I'm off and
running. But again, that's
really annoying. We can use
destructuring to do it one
better. We just say const, open
and close your curly brackets
there, to open and close the
destructuring syntax. Then we'll
say twitter and facebook are
going to be equal to... We
don't just say Wes here. We say
wes.links.social, and that will
then reach into the social
object and pull out two
variables called twitter and
facebook. Now, I just
consted twitter and I did that
up here as well. You can see my
editor is getting all red and
mad at me because I used that
variable already, so I'm just
going to comment that out and
it's good. Now if I look at
twitter, you see the link to my
actual Twitter. That is how
you do it with nested data.
Let's take a look at another use
case which would be renaming
your variables. Sometimes data
comes back in some odd names,
and you might not necessarily
want to use a property key.
For example here, I already used
twitter as a variable. I can't
use it again, but I'm stuck,
because this object gives me
twitter as a key and this object
gives me twitter as a key. What
you can do is you can rename
them as you destructure them.
You can say, I want the twitter
property, but I want to call it
tweet. I want the facebook
fb.  That's my snippet
text expander, I want to call it
fb. Let's see here.
Now I've got my tweet variable
and I have my fb variable, and
they are being destructured as
wes.links.social.facebook, but
then stored in a variable called
fb and stored in an actual
variable called tweet.
There's one last thing we need
to know about destructuring
objects, and that is the ability
to set defaults. This one's a
little bit confusing, so bear
with me here and we're going to
circle back for another example
later on in a couple of videos
with a function. Let's say
we have a function that's going
to do some animation on our page,
and it's going to create an
element and style it for us. We
have things like width, height,
color, and font size that we
want to set on this actual
element. We have that
settings object. Now I'm going
to create my own settings, so
settings equals...and we want
the width to be 300, and we want
the color to be black. Those are
our settings. However, the
thing that we're building also
requires a height and a font
size. Those are the four
properties that the thing that
we're building requires. How do
we actually deal with them when
they're not in there?
Previously what you'd do is
you'd have a default settings
object, then you would fold this
one in, you would merge it on in.
But with ES6 what we can do is,
we change that to const, and we
can create our variables here.
I'm going to say const, width,
height, color, font size equals,
then in here we are going to say
settings because that's this
variable. What that's going
to do is, it's going to pick out
the width, and it's going to
pick out the color from our
settings. But what about height
and front size? They haven't
been set in settings so they're
going to be undefined and that's
going to be a bit of a problem
for us. What you can do is,
when you do your destructuring
you can also set a fallback or a
default value. Maybe width is
default to 100, height is
default to 100 as well, color is
default to blue, and font size
is default to 25. What's
going to happen is, this
destructuring works like this.
Width, is it being destructured
from the settings object? Yes,
so width is going to be 300.
Height, is that being
destructured from the settings
object? No, it's not in there,
so it's going to roll back to
the default, 100. Color, is
that in there? Yes, so blue will
not be used. Black will win over.
Font size, that's not in there,
so we will use the default.
If I open this up in my browser
here, we should be able to see
the width. It's 300, good. The
settings took over. But let's
look at height, which is not in
the settings object. It's 100
because the default has fallen
in. Where this is going to be
real useful is when we pass a
settings object to a function in
just a couple of videos. I know
what you're asking right now is, "
Wes, I just learned all the
stuff about destructuring, but
can we put it all together into
one major thing?" I actually
wondered at that as well, so I
came up with this, which is...
Take a look at this.
Maybe pause it for a second, and
try to ask yourself, what is
going on here and what are the
variables that are being created?
I'm going to go open my DevTools
here. What are the variables
being created? Well, the
variables being created are
width and height. Why, because
it's destructuring W and H. But
it's renaming them to width and
height, so that I should be able
to say width. I guess I've got
to save first. Width and height,
good, so it's 800 and 500.
What's happening here is that
it's destructuring width from
this object here. It's going to
take 800, then it's immediately
renaming it to width, so it's
going to be 800. Then height,
what are these equals right here?
Those are default values. Height,
there is no H being passed at
all, so H tries to destructure
from the object here. It can't,
so it falls back to 500 default,
and then it renamed itself to
height. I'm not sure if you
would use that every day or it
maybe even every year, but it's
fun to look at it and to wrap
your head around. It's something
that you can maybe write and put
it on a t-shirt and be cool.
Enjoy that one.